i absolutely love your tick tocks thank
you
what's that a hat crazy funky junkie hat
you sucked hair inside me trying to look
like cute or nightly then there were two
i know you know what nobody likes us the
two [ __ ] are left
when are we getting these guys into your
tick tocks and why is that the place you
love
first off i think it's a much more um
easy flowing um
kinder community on tick tock uh i don't
know if they they get it so maybe one
day
we have no idea what you're saying i
know
ladies and gentlemen
selena gomez
[Music]
congratulations you just posted snl for
the first time this weekend you weren't
incredible thank you
how did you think i did i i thought you
had delivered the comedy so beautifully
and so
low-key but hilarious i really thought
have you ever wanted me to do something
like that no i don't think you'd be good
at it um you were actually in a skit
with her
yes
archie diligently recorded home footage
of dina's every move here dina is struck
by lightning while shaking someone's
hand hi mister nice to meet you
boom that was the hand buzzer what was
the experience like for you as a person
it was so much fun i had a blast i had
their support i had amy schumer's
support he had lauren's support it was
like it was a dream come true any advice
from steve before you did it uh uh you
know what they kind of helped me with a
few jokes
yeah we said go selena it's cool being
around two snl legends and when i found
out i was hosting i immediately asked
for their advice
steve said trust no one
and marty said i think steve martin has
been using my credit card
now we are so excited for season two of
the show oh goody the murderers are here
we were framed who will all of you on
the podcast still love that boom mike
you bet your ass i do kid well i don't
actually i returned it in the 30 day
window to get my deposit what can we
expect this time around more crime more
murder crime and murder yeah and murder
mixed with kind of an element of crime
dead yes and death
permeates really funny yeah
we can't tell you anything oh it's
honestly gonna be great we want it to be
the best one well this is the thing you
have para village and amy schumer
shirley mclean all part of the new
season how do they fit into the mix
we can't
everybody plays a character amy schumer
plays herself i think that's fair to say
yes
mclean does not play herself and then
you play yourself no matter what role
you're in absolutely because i have no
rain
[Music]
you